from
the he
said upon you is to hold on to the
original State of
Affairs that which they were upon before
splitting occurred before they split up
the people the Muslims split up yes the
Jews split into 70 71 sexs the
Christians into 72 sects and my was
split into 73 sets all of them
threatened with the fire except one
which one oh messenger of Allah in one
word he
said who's the the one like the which
one oh messenger of
[Music]
Allah that which I my companions are
upon that narration
is the great Scholars of Hadith over 25
Scholars of Hadith have accepted this
Hadith the of
in his different wordings after govering
all
the from this
Century from this Century the likes
of from the scholars of
and and other than from the scholars who
accepted this narration and the scholars
don't def over this narration
alhamdulillah in this
century is unanimous agreement of the
acceptance of this and it is quoted by
the of this century and the previous
century
and the previous Century this is quoted
by qued by is quoted
by is quoted
by these are narrations that are quoted
from the sah and
likewise all of that quoted from the
best people
the they the ones who brought us this
Hadith now they don't like thatth they
don't like any Hadith that goes against
them that's why we have to hold on to
the narration s some people might think
well you know you just why are you
bringing all this now we have to look at
the politics or the politics we have to
look at the Modern things they think
that salvation lies in let's learn how
to debate and so they have uh these
found debate foundations that they beg
people to put money towards so that they
can learn the art of gymnastics
Linguistics the art of how to argue they
think that salvation is in that
salvation is not in that salvation is to
return to because bar comes from Allah
not by your verbal gymnastics comes from
Allah
your and Allah said that in the
Quran verse 55
this is where the Salvation is they
worship me and don't associate par with
me in anything Allah's promisees is to
amongst those who believe amongst those
who believe and they do righteous Deeds
that he will give them inheritance upon
the Earth just as he gave it to those
who came before them and he will take
and he
will and he will make their Dean firmly
established uh
that which has made pleasing for them
and he will change their state of fear
from Fear to that of
security what is the
condition if we're upon
this worshiping Allah alone the worship
of the tongue the worship of the heart
the worship of the limbs keeping away
from shik shik major
minor we will come under this verse the
the promise of Allah G
Allah Will Bless The Allah will bless
them not because they went on a March
not because they went on demonstration
not because they're joking and sitting
around you know in these podcast sitting
around these innovators sitting around
in these pod joking and laughing and
let's have a good
laugh de is not it's not a joke it's not
a joke is about it's about it's about
it's
about it's about hoping to meet Allah
with your actions with your good deeds
this life is short and everybody will
come to know eventually but Allah's
messenger wasam has already laid out for
us the path of Salvation and is the path
of narrations the authentic narrations
so much salvation the best salvation the
best Guidance the guidance of wasallam
and following the way of the sah in the
explanation following the way of the
sahab and the in the explanation of the
of the Messengers and they ADH to
it look abdah beautiful narration this
great sah of the
Quran from those who narrated the most
from them
ISD from those who narrated the most
this B this ocean of knowledge the
prophet died
died whilst ABD was only 15 years
old and yet he and yet he was sitting
with the
elders Subhan Allah and he knew that the
verse
he knew this meant that the prophet is
going to die
soon when they were asking what does it
mean what does it mean he knew the
answer he
was before even 15 years all youth oh
young ones don't think it's too late
don't think you're too young I mean
don't think you're too young to learn
don't waste time this is the time to
learn to memorize Quran to learn meaning
to learn the Arabic language to learn it
to learn the books and to study the
books to learn and it meaning this is
the time to learn to learn the books of
a why not memorize the likes of
of our youth 8 years old 9 years old 10
years
old busy yourself yes with Quran but
memorize memorize memorize these these
texts because later on you will know the
beauty of these texts memorize
the so you know who your messenger is
memorize and know whom the messenger is
and we are all responsible we have
children put them in the madrasa let
them learn let them benefit and let them
know the Quran this is their salvation
and let them know its meaning teach them
follow them up yes the children time to
play and the time to be serious that's
for all of us you take your kids out
used to take his family out half term
used to come go out into the
in do that go out for a walk beautiful
walks around here it's better than
London here when you go out here there
waterfalls is beautiful do that in your
half turn
H remember that when it's time it's turn
time now they have to study that you be
with them that you follow them up let
them learn and teach them not to be
afraid of you first and foremost to be
afraid of Allah so when they're doing
something wrong you say to them Allah is
watching you you teach them as a sahab
used to say we used to teach our
children we used to teach our
children the not just the Quran but they
used to teach them
also the Sunnah they used to teach them
also
the and this is what we must do teach
our children how to pray how to fast how
to do zaka how to do the five pillars of
Islam and the six pillars of
IM he said I don't consider I don't
think that anyone upon the face of this
Earth that Shan wants more destroyed
than me ABD now saying this why he says
when he says okay how he says
because he said when a appears whether
in the East or the west and a man may
bring it to me questioning about this
B so when it reaches me I refute it and
suffice H and suffice it with the Sunnah
meaning I repel it with the Sunnah and
it is rejected H upon the one who said
it just as he brought it out just as he
said it it go it goes back to him and
this is how they clarify the Sunnah see
some people they say that oh you you
people enjoying good forbid evil always
enjoying good forbid evil Subhan Allah
enjoying good and forbiding evil is
the Allah said in the
Quran the Believers male and female
their friends and proteced of each
other there was Allah will have mercy on
I heard him with my own
ears he said look how Allah mentioned
enjoining good and forbidden evil before
establishing the prayer in this verse to
show you the importance of enjoying good
and
forbidden evil the statement ofd earlier
is in
also subh Allah
if you were to collect his statements
his his narrations Subhan Allah How
firm he was in establishing the Sunnah
and repelling
Innovations follow and do not innovate
for you have been sufficed he saw a man
with Beats this narration mentions it in
his a man
withs and he was using it abdah
took it from him cut it and he threw
it and he said just two two two
words you have been preceded you have
been preceded by the
sah this is not how we do we do with our
right hand like used do with with the
right hand of course we don't go
around
n cutting the people's B beads we don't
go around doing that who's ABD and he
had Authority those days abdah was the
sixth man to become Muslim abdah
[Music]
fromd was well respected no one's going
to
argue but we live in time of ignorance
nowadays people don't know or many
people don't know the Sunnah of use your
right hand Subhan
alhamdulillah use your right hand huh as
the scholars used to like this you are
like making a fist huh use your right
hand not your left hand use your right
hand do the sunah
of and then some people they would use
the ticket counter don't use ticket
counter use your right hand when you say
use your right hand they say brother I
can't count when he goes to the bank he
can count thousands but when he want
when he comes to dick he forgets I don't
know how that is he goes to the bank is
like 1,000 2,000 3,000 4,000 and he's
not missed one note huh one
is good counted then the only ticket
count have you ever seen any of these
individuals go into the bank with a
ticket count
out never seen anyone with a going to
the bank counting never but when it
comes to the de it become it's like all
of a
sudden economizing upon the Sunnah is
better than striving
on follow and do not innovate for you
have been sufficed Muhammad Hussein you
know who's Muhammad Hussein is
great
anyone it's important that we know these
names what's his book
IM look the book all of it is upon the
refuting and clarifying theah he called
it legislation see all this all the
groups they saying they don't realize
that sh starts with what following the
Sunnah and repelling how and you're
doing by calling the rulers ku All the
Muslims KU you are doing you are not
establishing sh and your the first group
that IM refuted were the that's the
first
group The and the book is called sh so
all of these individuals and we know
those individual shabab and they
apparently were in cardi weren't they
those youth with Clash noov they say
we're going to take over the world go
back and learn your Dean you're going to
little 16y old baby face is going to
take over the whole world learn your
Dean go and help your mother in the
garden go and learn how to pray go and
learn how
your go and learn that IM has levels and
kuur has levels the opposite go and
learn that you can't rush to perform
upon a Muslim
whoever says to his brother oh
disbeliever it falls on one of the two
and I'm saying this because we've seen
these
manipulative
callers at the gates of the AL calling
the shabab to what to destruction
calling these youth to destruction we've
seen it they they themselves don't go
out the likes of these heads of
they call themselves this head of in the
'90s he used to have a titled mecah the
state of shik Mak the state
of to that extent you're
making even of of of a blessed City when
the prophet
said there's no migration after theat of
Makkah meaning it's upon Islam and you
call it the state of sh this shows you
the ignorance they talk
about and they don't apply in their da
rulership belongs to Allah yes first and
foremost in your methodology in your
belief you don't believe in the
punishment of the
grave and you making of the Muslims not
just the rulers all of them you're
making of also the Islamic armies that's
hundreds of thousands of you're making
what kind of Islam is that
[Applause]
as for us we take our Dean from the sons
of the sah where did they take their
Dean from and one I said to him okay
name me one
scholar that saying what you're
saying he says they are hidden you see
Allah's de is apparent and he says they
are hidden how is hidden Allah's
messenger
said clearly upon the truth they will
not see to be a group upholding the
truth clear
it's not
hidden Islam is never hidden aldah Islam
in every generation you will find it
always uppermost in some part of the D
it will always be clear and Allah
mentioned that at the head of every
Century Allah's messenger mentioned that
the revivers of This Dean will revive
it which is
[Music]
at the head of every
Century he
said the sign of Allah wants good for
you the sign in a person that Allah
wants good for that
person treading this
path that is the path holding on to the
book of
Allah and the Sunnah of the messengeri
wasallam and the path of the
Companions and those who follow them
upon
righteousness and that which the schols
of the Muslims are
upon in every
[Music]
country
the the likes
of now is saying he start to mention
scholors in his time or those who came
before him and
suan and
Malik
and
anded and leaving off any path these
Scholars speak out against any path
whether it be the path of the sufis it
was said to IM sh about the sufis he
said if you stay with a Sufi at the
beginning of the day by the time you
reach D you'll be crazy why because you
see them dancing you see them twirling
you see them doing B you see them doing
sh by the time you got you get
to time it just takes that much time
from
to you gone that's IM what do you want
me to do what do you want me to say im
says that and it's true because from
their path is that they make their mids
blindf them and the teacher says to the
don't ask about what I do because you
don't know
you you don't know but I'm the sheh I'm
the man and I'm the W or the Wally
whatever he is I'm I'm the one and he
says to him whatever I so one this is in
their books W I'm telling you this is in
their books he sees his sh drinking
alcohol he says no no no I didn't I say
you don't ask they think they
like was
a he's a he said I didn't do it for
myself he's
a but they say no is and he's better
than
M because he had knowledge that M didn't
have huh they're trying to say that he's
by the
reputation and the proof
is I didn't do it for myself he's a and
Allah gave him guidance and I gave him
knowledge that M didn't have yes but he
a but the they try to say oh yeah look
this one and therefore is better than
it's not like that he not like that so
he says to him so he says to don't ask
about what I do just you do your dick do
your homework and don't ask about me and
they give them a homework to do on a
piece of paper they say go do this dick
and go just to get them away and I've
seen them with my own eyes this nak
bandi from Manchester I met one of his
students his mid his blind following
sheep and he was doing some he had
homework on a piece of paper doing
Dicker with a cloth over his head I said
what you're doing he I'm doing and I
looked at I said why don't you just take
the Muslim take the of take a book of
theah and do the dick of the Sunnah not
of your teacher that he makes up as he
goes along said no no no my teacher
knows if I've pray just by looking at my
face he knows if I've prayed F just by
looking like he's got special powers
supposedly anyway I try to give him
advice to the best of my ability then so
this Mor this teacher this this Mor this
is his teacher he says teacher you're
drinking
alcohol he says look then I tell you
don't ask when I drink it it turns into
milk I'm tell you this is in their book
I'm when I drink it huh it turns into
milk they so Pious is
alhamdulillah then the second one he
sees him again anyway this the story is
quite long but cutting it short he sees
him doing all hisat and in the end he
always has an answer for him and the
answer is like a supernatural answer
that obviously is a lie he a
that's why you have to stick to
the if you go
to at the last volume was
teaching in
makah during the week and in the last
volume it talks about these stories of
these
sufis and even even the youth ofnah they
used to know that these Sufi shakes were
you know phonies they were not real they
were not upon tawa they were not upon IM
they would lie to their to their
students they were lie to the people in
order to stay above board and they were
Li to them and you know about the many
stories that they come with that's why
you have to stick to the narration of
the IM Malik when he was said to them
there is a group of people dancing H in
the Masid he said are
they children he said they said know
they are grownup
men and so Malik laughed all the way
home he laughed all the way home and
even his students they said w we never
seen him laugh like that before he's
very serious but because of what you
said he couldn't believe that there
would be grown up men twirling and
dancing and believe me my dear brothers
I've seen it with my own eyes I've seen
it I was in one time in ha and there was
so much noise you know they put all the
British camps together all the countries
that come from for ha they put them all
together so they put all the British
camps in the same area okay with the
American camps and so on and next door
to us I could hear this loud
noise it's you trying to do say what the
prophet
said that's the
best what the Prophet said before me
that's the best you
say this if you say 100 times a
day protect you
from you have to always repeat
itan does not like it it's heavy on the
scales and so anyway we're trying to
concentrate but there's a lot of noise
next door so I just like this what's
this doing I'm just trying to see what
they're doing
and they are just running twirling it's
like they have to come to a state of
ecstasy where they just become and that
is they considered to be that is
considered to be to them and this is
this is exactly what said that if you
stay with them from to you become like
that you become like or you become crazy
and it's true why is this and some of
them and you've seen it in various
videos up north he just touches the man
the she the W or Wally touches the man
and the guy is like electric current
going through the whole body and he
starts dancing and falling all over the
place what is this what is this games
that they are playing what is these
games that they are playing with the
dean of Allah tala and with my own eyes
I've seen these BR as well dancing at
the graveyard even at the graveyard with
Tamarin even at the graveyard with your
Tamarin and
miracles you're supposed to supplicate
for the deceased not play your
instruments the ma and we've seen that
with our own eyes the gibberish that
they've got to the deviation that they
have reached that's Generations even if
the people were to have band in
us even if they were to beautify their
speech nothing if used to say even if we
see them walking on on the sea it
doesn't amaze us even if you see someone
walking on the bah it won't amaze us or
flying who cares fly and fall no problem
who cares that's not going to increase
me in my IM or some one of them he's
showing you how to do magic tricks in
the Masjid or he's hovering his legs up
his feet above the ground how is that
going to get me to Jenna or he's H he's
cutting Yellow Pages the same person
it's about entertainment it's about
deserting lights it's about spotlights
different colored spotlights no this
Dean is TAA this de is this is keeping
away from and this de is holding on to
the